you know this great commercial Virginia
Virginia since 2003 know you're living
where you go I stay with a friend we're
here in SRO on 6th and Stanford but I've
been intense when I first come out stay
in tents and in hotels and just random
places I tried to get a resident so I
got an income but they put me on a
waiting list and then they're giving me
the runaround like it's been taking
years and it's yeah I use crack I've
been using crack since I was since shoot
I guess 95 94 that's the only thing I
use them over yeah yeah pick one of
these bigger yeah what what age did you
start doing drugs after I had my
daughter when I was like 16 I had her
when I was 15
and then tell me about your car I had a
good job here just a normal average of
childhood my mom and dad took care of us
really well we had everything we need it
just took a little middle-class family
nothing big driving into it was very
just average you know I'm back in
Virginia we had a little Christmas it's
enough it was snowing we went sledding
and all this no no abuse nothing nothing
I mean I didn't smoke cigarettes didn't
drink my father mother
no no history and nobody in my family
drink or anything or even smoke
cigarettes or nothing and I'm the only
one that does it in our family my
brothers and sisters don't do it my
sister smoked cigarettes but they don't
drink they don't do drugs nothing I say
it's because of me because I did it and
they don't think they hate them so much
they despise it with such an anger and
fierceness which I'm glad that because
they seen what it did to me took me away
from them and having like for them and
they miss me and all that and how it put
me in jails and knocked up in this all
that stuff she's 26 and I've got an
annual granddaughter oh yeah yeah I've
got a lot of prostitution cases - yeah
yes numerous times or been to prison -
no I doubt here I did on 16 months we
have like I did nine months for
possession I got caught with a pipe it
wouldn't even no drugs he was just a
pipe for my record from back home with
really I was really off the hook
you know just outrageous prostitution I
had violence on my record all that stuff
so I'm not a violent person but I had to
defend myself it was a duty got obsessed
with me and stuff and he kept attacking
me and it's the police that stuff won't
do nothing about it because you know who
I was and who he was his mom was an
attorney so I was just a working woman
on the streets she wanted to work so I
didn't mean nothing
playing the kind of guys you think I
mean you must see all sorts right yeah
they got some weird ones you know like I
wonder that I'm so you wanna put needles
through my belly buttons and then he
wanted to put he put I was nodding off
because I'd been up too long I was going
towards really heavy then and that's
what really worked me up because um I
was not enough and he was taking me to
meet Donald stood awfully and I worked I
came to and I had shackles on my feet
and I was handcuffed and shackled I was
like I started panic I said am i under
arrest or something but the money was in
the bag he's like no the money's in the
bag that's just my thing he said I'm
gonna come back to wine on hand some
unlock you but he unlocked somebody left
a lock on my ankle and I couldn't get it
off and it was like I had to get my
friend to cut it off he said don't ever
do that again because that's dangerous
you know I'm saying and after that I I
never I got plenty of rats when I use
the drugs I stayed at home and all that
stuff you know that really old mines cuz
he did it to my friends that passed away
recently the guy crossed the street took
care of her until she passed recently
like named in a year a year ago in
February what was the year February she
only put clamps and then locks on her
nipples and he didn't come back and they
turned black and she almost lost her
breath her breasts he was really weird
up and the last time we need he kept
getting weirder and weirder you ain't
come through and stuff and so that last
time he gave me the money I was like I'm
not doing nothing
you call sent us a lot of problems down
here you're very sick and and he drives
a metro ran works for the Metro on
transportation the Train and he pulled
over there in front of the rest show his
place because like I'm gonna get the
police when I said go get him and when
you come out he said he said he seen me
and he was like [ __ ] you were in
a metro grant a company man you got a
prostitute in the car you went around
here trying to do weird stuff we've
heard about you get out here I'm gonna
call the company right now on you nice
to see there and I jumped out the van
and then he didn't back sense mm-hmm
well then there's another guy that
couldn't get me in the car this is the
last time this is that story but he kept
me in a car he tried to take me the
place where he wanted me going ons like
no I'm gonna go over here so he took me
over there and he was getting on top of
me to have sex and he started choking me
out and I started fainting I was gonna
he's gonna kill him I was gonna die and
a box gonna start sticking him with the
Box turn and he feeling his seat and
said oh God
I said that's right that's who need he
call him so I've got to call him bust a
window because I had my little ready or
like that and I bust the front
windshield well he took off
but the next day they found a girl
chopped in half one half of her was on
one side street the other half was on
the other side the exact place where he
tried to take me to begin with he came
back again and tried to get me and I
wouldn't go with him but my friend bust
his windshield out and he chased us in
the street and was running over the
parking meters and everything with his
calling we call the police and they
would not come like a half an hour
finally once he told his car took off
the next morning they found a girl under
the bridge her stomach was torn she was
gutted
every time he couldn't get me he got
somebody else and he's still out here I
guess cuz I they probably didn't catch
it it's sad you know him but he said God
God had him in with me because there was
a sick man they had another girl she was
out here she had her hands was like this
but she was a working girl and her son
had brain cancer and she was working and
she was sending all her money back there
for him to get treatment stuff back
wherever she was from and it's due to a
current chopped her my friend got in the
car with him at first he was I ran and
she felt funny she said I got a piece
and she got out the van it's a pea and
took off and then she went got in the
van with him and they found her chopped
up on olive and all the trashman's
body parts of her body parts for that
trash cans all up and down all the
street he got her you know cycle there's
some cbiit
you just really have to go with your
aura and your feeling you have to stay
sober and stay in a level mind and have
a clear mind when you go out there and
be very aware of what's going on and you
and you feel the different you feel it
from people when you're on them drugs
you might answer thing about getting the
drugs you're high you're twisting this
and it is a big difference because I can
see them coming when they even pull up
to me I'm like look I'm good I'm good I
could feel that I could see it if people
say ah it's gotta be somebody no it's
not because if you sit down you pay
attention you've been in streets of Ohio
you know you know you know the signs
it's a psychological thing in the
spiritual then you can no you just look
for little things or it's just little
feelings you can't explain like because
I feel them when they come in they see
and they see me they said they know they
ain't got they got me you don't saying I
could look at me and see they're like
like on her she ain't going for it you
know like an evil spirit if people don't
believe in the spirits but it's it's a
real world spiritual world really real
and it's really it's really scary but
it's missing horrific stuff that
happened not here that's my husband's
name Abdi Sheikh oh yeah yeah he's my
friend he just got out he's getting out
this week but he's back east he it's a
long story we come out here and he got
hit and ran over my car and the dude was
trying to kidnap me well he's trying to
go with me and my husband scared he was
gonna kidnap me so he jumped on the
truck fell off and we ran over him he
ran over him and with the truck I
thought he was dead and man was gonna
kill me and took me on he took me under
the bridge and was gonna kill me but I
took that truck around
[Music]
murder he went back there and got
involved with some female and they had
an argument and he was first be going
back to get physical therapy and come
back to get me his wife but he had an
affair and they got to a fight and he
wouldn't shot him in the face to his
going I things going shot the man in the
face I said I would now can you shoot a
man in the face over his wife and you
left your wife on the other side of the
[ __ ] country so I just don't get it
so I said another issue I gotta deal
with become you know I got to get to
divorce he wouldn't do it he wouldn't go
for it when I turn in papers so I don't
have to go through all that [ __ ] again
no I just smoked it I would never put a
needle in my own I can't it was hard
getting tattoos and then when I went to
jail I have seen all my first come out
and seen all the girls it's a long run
you got to stand in and the smell is all
over god overwhelming they have
abscesses and sores and stuff and their
socks have metal to their feet into the
sores and August pulling them off and
well no with crack you don't go through
withdrawals you playing hello moves cuz
you cranky or whatever no physically
it's not physically big no just heroin
extrinsic lady Utley you know they a lot
of people died for me the which borrows
are so bad but they have diarrhea
vomiting all this they're miserable yeah
well I can't get off of it I mean I've
done it before I just it's just
something to do right now and it's so
easy to get or what I was just something
to do it goes with the territory right
now with them because when I'm ready to
put it down and ain't looking back or
whatever I mean I got plans stuff that's
going out for me so this you know I'm
not gonna be one of these people who's
been out at 40 or 50 years and some of
them are 70 years old banana and raised
their kids down here on stuff and the
other kids is down here right
generations of people are down here and
it's like that's [ __ ] crazy they're
sad and they're proud of it they're like
I'm a downtown baby I'm a btg baby I'm
like well that's really sad because
they're proud of it but maybe they
understand I don't
yeah it really is